[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
momentan ist erdbeerzeit und ich freue
mich immer über die erdbeerzeit und
versuche sie auch dann wirklich immer
auszukosten und wirklich alles mögliche
mit etwa zuzubereiten erdbeer tiramisu
torturen apps alles mögliche und heute
gibt es bei windbeutel denn meine mama
hat morgen geburtstag und sie liebt
windbeutel so sehr deswegen mache ich
heute welche mit pistazien und zwar mit
so schönen pistazien kruste deswegen
werde ich jetzt erstmal diese kruste
zubereiten und später den brand stark
und ich zeige euch heute das windbeutel
wirklich sehr einfach sind in der
herstellung ist da keine angst davor
haben vertraut mir dafür nämlich 60
gramm pistazien und jeweils 50 gramm
mehl zucker und butter
und das erste was wir jetzt machen
wir werden jetzt erst mal die bis dahin
zerkleinern und damit jetzt kein
pistazien muss entsteht sehr kleiner ich
die pistazien direkt mit dem zucker und
kann sogar das mehl dazugeben in mixa
[Musik]
das war es schon
dann könnt ihr jetzt hier nämlich noch
die butter mit dazu mischen
minister auf die ist schön weich dann
kann man das ganz gut miteinander
vermischen
besser geht's doch doch am ende mit den
händen
und wenn ihr die masse dann soweit habt
als ihr seht auch die schön klebrig ein
schöner webtrekk tatsächlich
dann kommt auf und backpapier oder back
folie
denn das ganze wird jetzt schön
ausgerollt und später ausgestellten
ausgestochen
[Musik]
und am besten klappt ihr das jetzt zu
und rollt beim ausrollen starb drüber
und hier könnt ihr zum beispiel diese
drei millimeter rollen drauf machen dann
ist es auch richtig schön gleichmäßig
schaut jetzt habe ich eine richtig
schöne gleichmäßige machte ihr könnt es
auch gerne nochmal hier zusammenfalten
und hier da hat auch schönen abschluss
das passiert ist dann am ende aus
dann glaube ich dass hier einfach zu und
gips auf einen toten retter und kann es
einfrieren und in der zeit schon mal den
brand tag zu bereiten
für den teig nämlich 60 gramm butter
250 milliliter wasser etwas salz 200 g
mehl und vier bis fünf eier
ein brand tag wird auf dem herd
hergestellt ihr könnt aber auch falls
sie an der küchenmaschine mit hitze
funktion habt wie zum beispiel die cam
ward cooking chef könnte es auch gerne
dort machen denn beim brand tag ist so
dass jetzt butter wasser und salz
erstmal im topf ausgekocht werden
[Musik]
jetzt einmal aufkochen lassen und
dabei eine heiße kartoffel
wirkung reicht es gibt frühstück dort
morgen hier und werden kartoffeln
abgekocht für das videospiel
[Musik]
jetzt gebt ihr in einem schwung des mail
dazu das klingt am anfang ein bisschen
und dann ganz kräftig rühren okay
es sieht anfangs so ein bisschen falsch
aus aber es ist wirklich nicht falsch so
gehört und jetzt rühren rühren rühren
[Musik]
jetzt ihr den teig abgebrannt das ist
ein unterschied zum anbrennen und zwar
müsst ihr den teig hier so lange rühren
bis sich am boden des topfes und weißer
belag bildet und das ist auch ganz
wichtig damit später die windbeutel im
ofen auch schön aufgehen und diese luft
dann auch drin halten können und dann
nehme ich ihnen jetzt hier raus um das
den abkühlen so ein bisschen
und ich gebe es jetzt hier einfach in
die rührschüssel meiner küchenmaschine
und den topf lass dir jetzt einfach
abkühlen später löst sich nämlich diese
schicht vom boden von ganz alleine ab
und dann könnt ihr ihn ganz einfach
reinigen und diese schicht könnt ihr
sogar naschen ich finde das schmeckt
immer sowieso ein bisschen chips also
nicht wegschmeißen damit ist jetzt hier
schneller kühlt könnt ihr das ganze auch
so ein bisschen am topf land verteilen
oder einfach ein bisschen durchführen
einfach bis man so der erste dampf weg
ist und das ganze nicht mehr so heiß ist
damit die eier gleich noch mit dazu
können
ja und das war früher mal ziemlich
anstrengend denn jetzt kann ich es mit
der küchenmaschine machen früher habe
ich das tatsächlich mit dem bagger flug
macht und das ist dann schon anstrengend
ihr könnt aber auch in hand zurück gerät
mit knethaken nehmen das geht auch ganz
gut dauert noch ein bisschen länger als
mit der küchenmaschine aber es
funktioniert
und dann gibt jetzt hier das erste ei
dazu und last wirklich schön ein rührend
wenn jetzt nämlich zu viele eier rhein
gibt dann habt ihr das problem dass dies
nicht verbindet und das kriegt man
später dann echt auch nur ganz schwer
wieder gerettet
ich mache es auch so ich fühle mich
immer ein
und dann schön einzeln dazu geben
[Musik]
und es sieht echt immer anfangs außer es
wird sich das nie verbinden aber das
wird noch
wenn damit einen teigklumpen entstanden
ist das nicht seide zu geben
[Musik]
und es kommt jetzt immer so ein bisschen
auf die eier größe an deswegen sage ich
auch immer ganz gerne vier bis fünf eier
es können auch mal sechs eier sein denn
je nachdem wie groß die eier sind kann
es sein dass er etwas mehr oder weniger
braucht auf jeden fall nur soviel dazu
geben darf am ende eine schöne glänzende
masse entsteht
ja so sieht perfekt aus
guckt mal und zwar muss am ende die
masse so aussehen wenn ihr fragen quasi
das element oder den löffel rauszieht
muss eine glänzende spitzen stehen
jetzt verwende ich einen spritzbeutel
und eine lokale eine große und weil disc
wenig biss mit brands teigmasse die
brand masse immer recht fest ist und man
wirklich auch viel mit druck arbeiten
muss nämlich ganz gerne zwei
spritzbeutel
damit senat nicht auf platz die sind
zwar recht ganz gut muss ich sagen von
der qualität her aber auch brandtag ist
halt echt noch mal was anderes deswegen
könnte dort zwei übereinander nehmen
und da kurz rein film
man sieht es auch schon wie zähflüssig
die masse ist
und dann geht's los jetzt werden kleine
tupfer aufgespritzt
einfach senkrecht halten
da hat sich doch ein bisserl verstummt
da war noch einknickt
senkrecht halten unten anfangen
und dann nicht so groß denn das ganze
geht später im ofen richtig groß auf
[Musik]
dazu gegen ende könnte dann eine
tankkarte nehmen und den teig einfach
wieder vorsichtig nach vorne schieben
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt anfangs nicht getraut
aber es hat auch einen spritzbeutel
ausgereicht man kann die auch immer ganz
gut auswaschen
wenn ich was mit zubereitet habe dann
auf jeden fall mit spülmittel und essig
und der zweite beutel davy unbenutzt den
kann man auch weiter verwenden was war
spritzbeutel immer wichtig hier ist
lasst sie gut trocknen am besten über
nacht flasche oder zum beispiel über dem
spritzbeutel ständer zum beispiel bis
hin zur einweg beutel aber die sind echt
gut die naht ist auch echt gut und wie
gesagt also ich glaube hier deute eine
ausgereicht aber lieber zur sicherheit
im zweiten drittel
dann habe ich jetzt hier die fertigen
windbeutel normalerweise nehme ich immer
gerne stelle aber wie gesagt heute
machen wir eine kruste drauf und ich
probiert es jetzt einfach kurz abzählen
wie viel ich habe
[Musik]
warum habe ich das
metrische
820 und
dann kann ich jetzt hier nämlich kleine
kreise ausstechen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das schaffe ich das 20
ich nehme die kleineren mit einer
spritztour
und dann könnte das nämliche ausstechen
ich nehme ein anderes stück
sechseinhalb stunden später
eine ewigkeit später
und dann ausstechen und hier drauf
setzen ich bin sehr gespannt
[Musik]
ich finde wir sehen jetzt schon richtig
schön aus wie krieg ich mache das jetzt
auch zum ersten mal richtig gespannt
drauf im ofen gehen die jetzt noch
richtig auf ganz wichtig ist dass sie
den ofen nicht öffnet vor ende der
backzeit ansonsten fallen eure
windbeutel nämlich wieder zusammen da
sind keine windbeutel beiden sind
einfach nur so da sind denn so
zusammengedrückt jedenfalls erstes eine
blech packen dann das nächste falls ihr
2 habt auch gern parallel oder eben
nacheinander wenn ihr nur einen haupt
ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
ich habe hier noch ein bisschen von der
pistazien masse übrig und die bitte
nicht wegschmeißen ihr können sie
entweder verkaufen oder ihr macht daraus
crumble denn das ist ja butter zucker
mehl plus pistazie perfekte mischung für
ein crumble ich mache kurz eine
resteverwertung ich nehme einfach äpfel
zitronen das kommt in so kleinen
förmchen und dann diese pistazie des
britisch fürs mehl
da kann ich nämlich noch bislang mail
ein denn für krempel ist es noch zu
wenig mehl und da könnt ihr hier auch
äpfel nehmen die so ein bisschen schon
gleich sind und so ein bisschen
ausgetrocknet und am schönen nachtisch
noch hier für uns und danach werde ich
gleich die erdbeer maße schon mal zu
bereiten denn die kann ich auch schon
bereit machen
[Musik]
das sind schöne kram borussia
nein aber ich freue mich ich habe wieder
offen reingeguckt sieht so schön aus
während die windbeutel jetzt noch schön
backen ich mache den crumble einfach
danach kann ich jetzt schon mal die
erdbeer creme vorbereiten denn ich
möchte jetzt gleich eine creme aus
erdbeeren weiße schokolade sahne und so
weiter aber ich muss die erdbahn
einkochen und brauche jetzt 200 gramm
erdbeeren die sind bereits vom grünen
befreit wobei ich immer sagen muss dass
grünen kann man mitessen nur vielleicht
erzählen der kredit aber in einem
smoothie zum beispiel schon und 100
gramm kuvertüre dem ich jetzt weiße
schokolade
es gibt da einfach die erdbahn in topf
und zerdrückte so ein bisschen und last
so schön einkochen
das wird jetzt praktisch eine fruchtige
ghana
dazu statt sahne aufzukochen führe ich
einfach die erdbeeren fein und kochte
auf und dann kommt hier eben die
schokolade rein
[Musik]
die konnte canon spritzer zitronensaft
dazugeben
aber dass die farbe der app ganz schön
erhalten bleibt
mit graz 1 2 minuten köcheln
dann den herd ausschalten und die
schokolade einrühren
[Musik]
dann ist die garage fertig wenn er sie
ganz fein haben wollt könnt ihr sie auch
gern noch pürieren ich muss aber sagen
dass mich die fruchtstückchen das netz
stürmt ich will sie jetzt um lasse dann
abgedeckt abkühlen und stellt sie dann
in den kühlschrank damit sie richtig
schön kühlschrank kalt wird und die
windbeutel hole ich gleich aus dem ofen
raus wenn sie fertig sind wie gesagt vor
hat den ofen nicht öffnen und dann geht
es gleich mit dazu bereit und bequem als
wahlleiter würde ich sagen
[Musik]
das habe ich hier die abgekühlte erdbeer
schokoladencreme dann etwas man den
extrakt 250 gramm quark 300 gramm sahne
50 gramm puderzucker wenn ihr möchtet
und dann hat zum start schlagen
puderzucker wirklich nur dazu geben wenn
die erdbeeren vielleicht noch nicht tief
genug waren oder euch die creme nicht
süß genug wird aber probiert gerne
erstmal aus ihr freund aus münster
zitiert
[Musik]
dann waren den extrakt dazu
kommt gleich aus der flasche raus einen
moment
da
den quark mit rein
dann erstmal verrühren
[Musik]
und wenn dann alles schön cremig ist die
sahne dazu gießen
ich nehm den ganzen aber zurück
und ganz schön mit seiner bahnsteigs
lagen
[Musik]
dann stelle ich die creme kurz in den
kühlschrank
jetzt könnte ich hier dieser windbeutel
die so wurden doch schön aufgegangen
sind sieht man gut gab könnte jetzt
aufschneiden und zwar am besten mit
seinem geriffelten messer
dann flach hinlegen
und aufschneiden
dann fühle ich die creme jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel 1 da hab ich jetzt wieder
eine große loch trainer dran
so einfach dem spritzbeutel von vorhin
natürlich ganz sauber
dann kann das kurz zur seite und wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch gerne beim
rhein füllen
ich habe jetzt hier einfach mal ein paar
die ich kurz
in scheiben schneiden
und so tatsächlich am schnellsten
[Musik]
damit euch jetzt hier sind
dringend was andere machen müssen
[Gelächter]
dann hätten wir euch jetzt hier den
aufgeschnittenen windbeutel und eure
creme
die wird denn das schön rein gespritzt
so viel wie ihr halt möchte
gerne dann noch zwei erdbeer schreiben
drauf
[Musik]
und wer möchte
kann noch bis zur süßen schnee darüber
geben
oder sogar etwas glitzer schnee
richtig
die restlichen windbeutel befülle ich
noch bin ich sie bis morgen aufheben
möchte für meine mama zum geburtstag
dann ist es am besten wenn sie nicht
befüllt werden das heißt die windbeutel
könnte so hervorragend vorbereiten dann
am besten luftdicht verpacken und bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen die creme
im kühlschrank lagern und morgen dann
ganz frisch befüllen ich würde sagen den
einen hier den fahrkosten mails der rest
ist im kühlschrank
jasmin kannst du gleich aus dem keller
kommen ich komme danke ich hab auch zum
probieren für dich
war unter viel unordnung ist alles in
ordnung aufgeräumter
weiter rein ja ja die hat mich gerade am
entrümpeln des kellers hierunter garage
wirtschaft viel arbeit muss sein
nachbar
zum verfüllen gottwald magst mir die
beutel hast ja ja ja ja ja nur ist das
probieren vor der kamera eines
windbeutel es nicht ganz so elegant
möglich das ist auch meine sache ich mir
gedacht habe ich schneide ihn auch das
so gut dass nur so viel man sich glaube
ich wird das hier nichts heute das
kriegen wir sonst hin das ist aber jetzt
kein üblicher windbeutel oder
yahoo normalerweise hat er ja ist da
noch schokolade drauf und diese creme
aber ich sehe ja genau der hatte
passend zu sagen
es geht auch mit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
minimal
ich brauche auf jeden fall ein thema
und wir haben es geschafft
der war
richtig lecker
[Gelächter]
ja die war richtig fruchtig frischen und
malaga
dann
werden wir sagen euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken würdest du es ja auf jeden
fall mal ausprobieren ich würde sie
ausprobieren ja ich hoffe ich kriege ich
muss sagen ich die windbeutel sogar so
ungefüllt ja das schmeckt an und die
kruste ansicht die gibt ja dann ganz
normal
gerne auf das rezept findet die aus
tennis - blog.de
nachdem der kamera deswegen vor den
konsum wird wir würden deswegen sich das
bild auch
oder in meiner app findet ihr das rezept
natürlich auch also viel spaß und nach
backen bis zum nächsten mal das
budget für die mama morgen
[Musik]